le chant de gorge est un duel où la
perdante sera celle qui rira en premier
lieu de cette tradition inuit
eva et manon en ont fait un film est un
fait parce que j'aime faire le chantre
de gorge puis je veux le personnes voire
voir voir quoi pour une trop rare fois
l'expression de leur culture inuit
ce court métrage intitulé chants de
gorge tensyr souks et le premier contact
avec la réalisation cinématographique
pour ces deux adolescentes de la
communauté de pnb au nunavik c'est grâce
au wapikoni un laboratoire de création
pour les jeunes autochtones qu'il a pu
voir le jour
cette culture là elle n'est pas très
connue elle est très favorisés et là ça
va dans quelque chose de très
contemporain avec des jeunes filles qui
exprime une réalité avec des moyens
techniques contemporain et qui peuvent
se confronter à n'importe quel cinéaste
de n'importe quelle origine des
auditions du dollar en plus du chant
traditionnel dans ce film de trois
minutes
on y voit des paysages arctiques tourné
à vol d'oiseau les images sont à couper
le souffle pour ses créatrices qui parle
hinault petit tout français et anglais
c'est aussi une façon d'exprimer les
douleurs du passé comme nous sommes les
seuls à chanter en public
est ce que j'entends parfois la douleur
de certains d'entre nous d'avoir été
séparé de ses parents dit elle le court
métrage sera présenté en première
mondiale au festival du film de sundance
vendredi en plus d'être en compétition
pour l'équipe du film
c'est une occasion inespérée de france à
cause de la force du film et de son
humour ça va continuer de réveiller
l'intérêt pour tout ce qu'on a exprimé
ses cultures leurs cette jeunesse là
chants de gorge acte nguesso se taillera
t-il une place dans le coeur du jury ce
court métrage aura tout de même fait son
chemin à 5000 kilomètres de la maison
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal